ruinen an der küste lettlands die vom
vergangenen schlachten zeugen
sie sind so stark zerstört dass es
aussieht als hätte eine riesige
explosion alles auf einmal gesprengt
ein schauriger gebäudekomplex mit einem
düsteren geheimnis aus dem zweiten
weltkrieg
ich kann die experimente die folter
förmlich vor mir sehen
reste einer wüstenstadt die auf ein
besonderes schicksal zurückblickt
irgendetwas hat diese bauten dem
erdboden gleich gemacht und alle
zeugnisse menschlicher besiedlung
vernichtet
und eine monumentale anlage in den
bergen südafrikas in der ein tödlicher
stoff zu tage gefördert wurde
was dieses material besonders macht ist
gleichzeitig gefährlich
zerfallene bauten ruinen aus vergangener
zeit einst mühsam erschaffen heute nur
noch schatten ihrer selbst zeit ihre
geheimnisse zu lüften
[Musik]
nördlich von berlin am rande der
kleinstadt oranienburg stehen diese
verkohlten überreste einer verstörenden
vergangenheit
es ist schwer zu sagen was das ist ein
großer hangar tiger bau in dem offenbar
etwas wichtiges hergestellt wurde ist
hoch gesichert bewacht und abgeschieden
gelegenen warum
es wirkt unscheinbar ist außerhalb der
stadt hinter bäumen versteckt was immer
es ist es ist geheimnisvoll
im innern gibt es hinweise auf die
dunkle vergangenheit der anlage
wenn man reinkommt sieht man diese
großen räume und diese riesigen öfen
ganz offensichtlich war es hier extrem
heiß es gibt es flecken an den wänden
und an der decke hinweise auf feuer
losen deutschen bause die ziegelsteine
gasleitungen und wasserhähne denke ich
an die furchtbarsten dinge die sich hier
zugetragen haben müssen
aber hier ist nicht das passiert was man
zuerst denkt die geschichte ist ein
bisschen anders
was aber ist hier passiert
und warum steht das gebäude noch heute
wer das geheimnis lüften will muss etwa
drei kilometer weiter fahren zum
konzentrationslager sachsenhausen
zwischen 1936 und
1945 waren hier mehr als 200.000
menschen inhaftiert
zunächst vor allem gegner des
naziregimes dann immer mehr juden
homosexuelle sinti und roma und andere
menschen die die nazis als
minderwertig einstuften
zehntausende kamen durch hunger
krankheiten zwangsarbeit und
misshandlungen um nach denen
novemberpogrome 1938
wurden allein 6000 juden nach
sachsenhausen deportiert zu beginn des
zweiten weltkriegs worten die nazis die
konzentrationslager aus auch um die
häftlinge als zwangsarbeiter in der
kriegs wirtschaft einzusetzen
sachsenhausen liegt am rand von berlin
die deutschen sollten nicht allzu viel
von der existenz des lagers mitbekommen
je näher die nazis das politische leben
bestimmen desto mehr menschen ruhen sie
von den berliner straßen und aus den
umliegenden städten und sperren sie hier
ein
das lager ist nur ein baustein des
terrors
auch der verfallende bauer in der nähe
ist schauplatz grausamer verbrechen
und auch hier wurden häftlinge zur
arbeit gezwungen
man muss die sieben tage die woche
arbeiten die essensrationen waren winzig
das waren zwar keine vernichtungslager
aber die menschen wurden dort zu tode
geschunden
dies ist die ss brotfabrik ein ort an
dem die zwangsarbeiter brot für ihre
peiniger backten post differenz von der
stiftung brandenburgische gedenkstätten
kennt die geschichte dieses orts diese
großen öfen oder die reste davon die wir
hier sehen haben tag für tag tausende
von broten produziert und für die 60
später bis zu 100 häftlinge des
häftlings kommandos das hier in der
bäckerei zwangsarbeit leisten musste war
es natürlich wahrscheinlich eine qual
ansehen zu müssen dass hier in hülle und
fülle nahrungsmittel produziert wurden
während sie selber und ihre mithäftlinge
im lager furchtbaren hunger leiden
mussten
die bittere ironie für viele
zwangsarbeiter war die fabrik auch mit
der hoffnung verbunden dem tod durch
verhungern zu entrinnen
die insassen der konzentrationslager
wurden systematisch zu tode gehungert
ein stück rinde das vielleicht in einem
der häfen von einem der brote abfiel
konnte den unterschied zwischen leben
und tod bedeuten
man könnte meinen dass es keine große
sache wäre sich einen brot cruise zu
nehmen oder ein stück kruste vom boden
aber die deutschen hatten das verboten
sie verlangten unbedingten gehorsam und
bestraften jeden verstoß gnadenlos
trotz der gefahren letzte hunger manchen
insassen keine andere wahl wir haben
leider nur einen häftlings bericht der
etwas ausführlicher über die brotfabrik
berichtet von einem kommunistischen
häftling der überlebende berichtet dass
sie bei der brot ausgabe brotlaibe ins
selber ins lager hineingeschmuggelt
haben indem sie brot leidet leibe der
länge nach halbiert haben und dann mit
schnüren um ihre wagen herum gefunden
haben das sie von den weiten hosenbeinen
bedeckt waren und sie sie auf die art
und weise in das er in das lager
mitnehmen konnten natürlich war das sehr
gefährlich
die lebensbedingungen der gefangenen im
lager sind unmenschlich und
es dient nach einem anderen zweck hier
werden kz kommandanten und das
bewachungspersonal für lager im ganzen
machtbereich der nazis ausgebildet
wir befinden uns jetzt im zweiten
obergeschoss des sogenannten thoms des
zentralen wachturms durch den auch die
häftlinge des häftlings lager betragen
und hier oben war ein maschinengewehr
postiert mit zwei wochen die ihr tag und
nacht standen und zum modellcharakter
von sachsenhausen gehörte dass die
wachmänner die hier oben stehen das
gesamte häftlings lager von diesen
zentralen punkt aus kontrollieren können
sachsenhausen ist als kz konzipiert dass
die absolute macht der ss auch
architektonisch ausdrückt das lager ist
in der form eines gleichschenkligen
dreiecks angelegt
so haben die wächter freie sicht und
freies schussfeld über das ganze gelände
mann wurde erschossen entweder vom turm
aus oder von einem anderen wachturm aus
niemand durfte entkommen denn die nazis
brauchten die zwangsarbeiter und wollten
nicht dass jemand erzählt was in den
lagern passiert
natürlich auch ein psychologischer die
häftlinge wo sie sich auch im lager
bewegten schauten hier auf diesen
wachturm von überall aus war er zu sehen
schauten in den lauf ging es dieses
maschinengewehrs so dass hier auch
symbolisch die totale macht der ss zum
ausdruck kam
als modell kz spielt sachsenhausen auch
in anderer hinsicht eine wichtige rolle
mitte der 30er jahre begann die nazis
damit konzentrationslager zu konzipieren
anfangs heuer die polizisten und auch
zivilisten an
in sachsenhausen wurden ganz normale
deutsche zu ss mördern ausgebildet
in der ss brotfabrik wird das brot für
die schergen des menschenverachtenden
systems gebacken und der hunger der
nazis wächst
deutschland 1939 den zweiten weltkrieg
beginnt und massenhaft mobilisiert
reservisten einzieht die wehrpflicht
erweitert wird auch mehr brot gebraucht
um die truppen rund um berlin zu
ernähren
[Musik]
anfangs ist die produktion moderat etwa
10.000 laibe pro tag im laufe der zeit
wird die produktion in der fabrik für 4
oder verfünffacht
was in sachsenhausen erprobt wird wird
in anderen konzentrationslagern kopiert
deutschland hat die sklaverei neu
erfunden und das prinzip in eine
gigantische dimension übergeführt
das ist ein frühes beispiel für ein
industrieunternehmen der ss
es diente als modell für andere größere
industrielle projekte mitte des zweiten
weltkriegs war die ss einer der größten
industriekonzerne im dritten reich
zwangsarbeit wird eine tragende säule
der ns kriegsmaschinerie der
berüchtigte satz arbeit macht frei ist
an zynismus kaum zu übertreffen
tatsächlich hatte natürlich arbeiten
konzentrationslager eine ganz andere
funktion
arbeit war immer auch ein instrument um
häftlinge zu misshandeln zu wählen zu
foltern auch zu tode zu bringen
und dies verschleiert dieser begriff
natürlich vollkommen in einer wendung
des schicksals wird die brotfabrik die
die ss schergen ernährt hat zum
rettungsanker für die wenigen insassen
die bis zum ende des zweiten weltkriegs
überleben sowjetische truppen befreien
das lager im april 1945
die sowjets entdeckten die brotfabrik
und nahmen sie wieder in betrieb um ihre
truppen und die verbliebenen 3000
gefangenen zu versorgen für die insassen
muss das fantastisch gewesen sein jeden
tag hatten sie hungrig auf diese
tausenden laibe brot gstaad und endlich
durften sie sie essen
x factor es menschen in diesem kz
überlebt haben grenzt an ein wunder und
dass es in der direkten umgebung diese
fabrik gab die sie ernähren konnte war
ein segen
die brotfabrik bleibt noch bis in die
1990 er jahre in betrieb dann wird sie
durch ein feuer zerstört
zusammen mit dem lager sachsenhausen ist
sie heute zeugnis des schwärzesten
kapitel der deutschen geschichte diese
orte sind die realen tatorte der
nationalsozialistischen verbrechen sie
bezeugen dass es diese lager gab das ist
diese verbrechen gab und dass man sie
nicht
absteigt abstreiten und leugnen kann und
wir denken dass diese baulichen
zeugnisse der lager auch in zukunft eine
umso größere bedeutung gewinnen werden
weil die menschen die terror der ss in
diesen lagern überlebt haben bald nicht
mehr unter uns sein werden
im stop trocknen flachland nevadas
kilometer weit entfernt von der
zivilisation
bröckeln ruinen vor sich
das ist ein unwirtlicher ort mitten in
der wüste die sonne brennt von oben und
man fragt sich wie es zu diesem maß an
zerstörung kam
alles ist fast komplett kaputt wie man
es sonst eher von sehr alten ruinen
kennt aber wenn man näher hinsieht
entdeckt man dass es gar nicht so alt
sein kann da gibt es nämlich reste von
beton
irgendetwas ist hierdurch gerauscht und
hat alles weggefegt
die nähere untersuchung dieser seltsamen
ruinen deutet auf eine reihe bizarrer
ereignisse
bei der suche nach hinweisen fallen
diese baumstämme auf die alle
abgebrochen sind und alles ist stark
verwittert es gibt keine kanten keine
rechten winkel alles ist abgerundet
das seltsamste ist das hier mitten in
der wüste über einen muscheln
herumliegen möglicherweise liefern die
eine erklärung dafür was hier passiert
ist
[Musik]
es ist extrem heiß hier wir sind in der
movavi wüste wo es im sommer bis zu 45
grad heiß werden kann das wichtigste ist
hier immer genug wasser dabei zu haben
in altenburg ist archäologen bei der
nationalparkverwaltung und hat die
ruinen untersucht sie weiß dass die
gegend trotz der sengenden hitze
durchaus ihre vorteile hatte
ein ziemlich unwirtlicher ort aber die
flüsse virgin und mark webber sind ganz
in der nähe die bewohner haben sich mit
den gegebenheiten arrangiert und hier
über 70 jahre lang gelebt
mitte des neunzehnten jahrhunderts gab
es hier eine kleine landwirtschaftlich
geprägte mormonen siedlung doch schon
als sich die gruppe hier niederließ
legten sie den keim der zerstörung ihres
dorfes
als die ersten siedler 1865 ankamen war
das hier das ende der welt sie dachten
sie seien noch innerhalb der grenzen von
utah aber tatsächlich waren sie schon in
nevada
der steuerprüfer auftauchte und ihnen
mitteilte dass sie nicht in utah waren
beschlossen sie weiter zu ziehen und
brannten die stadt nieder aber das was
wir jetzt hier sehen ist schon die
nächste stufe der stadt die
folgegeschichte
die ersten siedler verließen ihr dorf
als verkohlte ruine
aber die nächste zerstörung steht
bereits bevor
doch dieses mal ist der grund ein ganz
anderer das ist die geisterstadt vom
sein thomas
nach denen die mormonen die stadt
verlassen hatten kamen die nächsten
siedler sie betrieben landwirtschaft
bauten ein dorf und lebten ein einfaches
aber unabhängiges leben
die siedlung war abgeschieden in der
wüste aber sie hatten alles was sie
brauchten sie hatten sich gut
eingerichtet
die bewohner von 10 thomas leben wie am
ende der welt
doch alte eisenbahngleise am rande der
ehemaligen stadt zeugen davon dass das
nicht so bleiben wird
anfang des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts wird
die welt kleiner amerika boomt überall
werden bahn linien gebaut die
bevölkerung wächst und das leben bietet
viele neue chancen und das macht auch
den leuten hier große hoffnungen
am anfang bringt der fortschritt den
bewohnern der stadt wohlstand nachdem
die schienenanbindung fertig ist folgt
das straßennetz
das ist die hauptstraße von symptomen
wie man sieht war sie ziemlich breit und
bot genug platz für pferde kutschen und
später für autos sind thomas war
zwischenstopp auf dem weg von los
angeles nach salt lake city und hinter
diesem stümpfen standen häuser und
geschäfte
nicht nur für die einheimischen sondern
auch für die reisen denn die durch die
stadt kamen
die stadt dient sich inzwischen auf fast
einen quadratkilometer aus es gibt
allerlei geschäfte werkstätten und sogar
einer eisdiele
umgeben ist sie von ackerland auf dem
die farmer des ortes weizen baumwolle
und gemüse anbauen
zu hochzeiten leben 500 menschen hier
sie hoffen auf eine rosige zukunft
zu diesem zeitpunkt ist zum thomas eine
etablierte gemeinde es gibt eine schule
einen friedhof das dorf hat eine
vergangenheit und eine zukunft und von
einem tag auf den anderen ändert sich
alles bei einem spaziergang durch die
ruinenstadt kann man erahnen wie sich
das leben hier an gefühlt haben muss
doch es gibt auch hinweise darauf was
ihren untergang herbeigeführt hat
solche muscheln findet man normalerweise
nicht in der wüste die gibt es eher am
meer aber sie liegen hier überall herum
und sie können erklären was hier
passiert ist
wer in der wüste überleben will braucht
wasser aber wasser führte letztendlich
zum untergang dieser siedlung
ein dramatisches ereignis steht bevor
die staubtrockenen straßen von zehn
teams werden von einer flut biblischen
ausmaßes überschwemmt
das wasser erreicht es sein thomas 1938
es überschwemmte straßen und gebäude bis
die ganze stadt 20 meter unter wasser
stand
die wüstenstadt zentrums gibt es nicht
mehr
das muss wirklich bizarr gewesen sein
mitten in der wüste plötzlich von wasser
überflutet zu werden
vielleicht sind die bewohner aber gar
nicht so sehr überrascht worden denn
warnungen gab es schon in den jahren
davor
schon in den 1920 er jahren war eines
der größten bauprojekte des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts angekündigt worden der
hofer dann
wir sind hier in lag mit nevada in der
nähe des hoover damm am unteren ende des
sees erstreckt sich über fast 140
kilometer bis zum oberen ende wo der
colorado river hineinfließt
der einheimische christopher henzler
fährt seit 40 jahren auf diesen
gewässern
als der hoover damm gebaut wurde füllte
sich der see- und das wasser überflutete
die täler heute ist es hier fast 140
meter tief
und der see bedeckt ungefähr 1200
quadratkilometer
1931 beginnen die arbeiten an dem damals
höchsten dann der welt
die idee hinter dem hoover damm war die
energie des colorado flusses zu nutzen
um daraus strom zu erzeugen das wasser
wurde aber auch zur bewässerung genutzt
um die wüste erblühen zu lassen
der hoover damm kam vielen menschen in
verschiedenen staaten zugute doch einige
mussten einen hohen preis dafür zahlen
mit plus für die bewohner von symptoms
war das projekt auf persönlicher ebene
eine katastrophe ihre häuser wurden
einfach weggespült
ihre vorfahren und ihre geschichte
wurden meterhoch von wasser bedeckt
bäume werden abgesägt und alles von
werth aus der stadt geschafft
als der wasserpegel weiter steigt
verlassen die letzten bewohner ihre
häuser
doch wenn die wüstenstadt geflutet
worden ist warum ist sie heute wieder in
der wüste
die antwort liefern die wasserstands
marca an den felsen
[Musik]
100 voll ist oben an der weißen linie
und heute sind wir bei 42 prozent 40
meter unter der markierung das letzte
mal waren wir im jahr 2000 bei 100
prozent seitdem fällt der pegel stetig
jahrzehntelange dürrn und der steigende
wasserverbrauch lassen das reservoir
immer weiter schrumpfen deswegen ist 10
thomas heute eine ruinenstadt in der
wüste und nicht mehr eine unter wasser
heute ist ein tolles ein mahnmal dafür
dass der wasserverbrauch in unserer
wachsenden modernen welt besser
reguliert werden muss
[Musik]
das problem ist es gibt nicht genug
wasser es ist ein endlicher rohstoff und
wir müssen sparsam damit umgehen wasser
ist die wertvollste ressource in der
wüste es ist das neue gold
an der küste lettlands stehen eine reihe
baufälliger ruinen die langsam ins meer
abrutschen
wenn man an die schöne natur belassene
ostseeküste lettlands kommt und dann
diese gebilde sieht die am strand liegen
und fast wie ufos aussehen die da
gelandet sind mit diesen riesigen rädern
und betonplatten
man sieht diese großen
betonkonstruktionen die auseinander
gebrochen sind und das schränkt als wäre
hier eine große katastrophe passiert
das war da wurde enormer aufwand
betrieben um so etwas großes zu bauen
merkwürdige türme überwucherte bunker
und andere befestigungsanlagen stehen in
unmittelbarer nähe und das ist noch
nicht alles
weiter landeinwärts sind noch gebäude
ganz anderer bauart ihre architektur ist
kunstvoller aber sie sind auch zerstört
und verfallen
dieses maß der zerstörung an beiden
orten zeigt hier muss etwas schrecklich
schiefgelaufen sein
vor 100 jahren tobte hier eine blutige
schlacht
doch berichte darüber suchte man in
vielen geschichtsbüchern lange
vergeblich
heute geben diese ruinen ihr vergessenes
geheimnis preis
ende des 19 jahrhunderts liegt dieser
küstenabschnitt an der grenze des
russischen reiches
als die anlage gebaut wird ist die welt
im umbruch
1890 fiel die alte allianz zwischen
russland und deutschland allmählich
auseinander und die russen sahen die
deutschen als wahrscheinliche zukünftige
feinde an
das zarenreich richtet sich strategisch
neu aus und konzentriert sich voll auf
die verteidigung der ostsee
der zahl es den hafen von der hpa
befestigen um der wachsenden deutschen
bedrohungen etwas entgegensetzen zu
können
die geschichte wird zeigen dass das ein
fehler ist
heimatforscher christus kraft kennt die
anlage gut
auf den ersten blick scheint sie eine
hervorragende position für artillerie
geschütze zu bieten
wir sehen hier einen kleinen teil der
küsten befestigungen dies ist batterie
nummer eins an der küste gibt es
insgesamt acht das geschütz hier war auf
einer drehbaren plattform installiert
und konnte in alle richtungen schießen
egal woher die schüsse kamen
um die befestigungen zu belangen wird
ein großes truppenkontingent stationiert
das ziel war eine gigantische küsten
befestigung zu errichten sie sollte
uneinnehmbar sein dies sind die forst
von carossa sie gehören zum früheren
russischen ostseehafen lea meyer und das
ist nur ein teil eines weitaus größeren
verteidigungssystems gegen den
erwarteten deutschen angriff
sie bauten eine große monat die etwa
anderthalb kilometer ins meer ragt sie
bot großen kriegsschiffen schutz
die fonds sind dort entlang gebaut dem
ganzen strand entlang damit feindliche
schiffe den hafen nicht angreifen ihn
blockieren oder beschießen konnten
vom hier erstrecken sich die
verteidigungslinien ins inland
er wollte den hafen zu einer befestigten
stadt ausbauen das gebiet war riesig
über 35 quadratkilometer groß mit
verteidigungsanlagen an der küste und
mauern und gräben im inland und alle
waren mit den mächtigsten geschützen
ausgestattet die es damals gab
im inneren der anlage gibt es alles um
den hafen in betrieb zu halten und die
festung zu verteidigen
die befestigungsanlage war riesig sie
bot der marinebasis und im hafen von
liepaja schutz in dem mehr als 100
kriegsschiffe lagen und rund 20.000
soldaten stationiert waren es gab
unterkünfte für alle munitionslager
labore ausbildungsstätte nervten usw
doch karosse hat auch schwachstellen
der größte vorteil war dass der hafen
das ganze jahr über eisfrei war doch die
schwachstelle der anlage und
paradoxerweise gleichzeitig der grund
ihrer existenz war die nähe zu
deutschland
das hauptproblem liegt keine 100
kilometer entfernt nämlich der
nächstgelegene deutsche hafen der
damaligen stadt nehmen wenn es zum krieg
käme wäre man direkt an der frontlinie
und es wäre ein großes risiko den
großteil seiner flotte an der front zu
stationieren
es dauert 13 jahre karosser zu bauen
als die anlage 1906 fertiggestellt ist
ist nicht mehr nur die lage ein problem
im prinzip war die anlage ihrem
eigentlichen zweck nicht mehr gewachsen
die militärtechnologie hatte sich rasant
weiterentwickelt schneller als alles
andere es war sinnlos die befestigungen
weiter zu betreiben
das problem die gesamte anlage ist nicht
mit eisen bewährt neue große
artilleriegranaten können die bauten mit
leichtigkeit durchbrechen also wird die
festung nach nur zwei jahren aufgegeben
sie ihre strategie überdachten stellten
sie fest dass die ganze sache nicht
funktioniert als der erste weltkrieg
ausbricht ist das vor nur noch eine
unbedeutende militärische anlage
nach der aufgabe der nördlichen force
sprengen die russen die befestigungen
die reste überlassen sie ihrem schicksal
wahrscheinlich wäre das vor im ersten
weltkrieg sowieso zerstört worden wenn
der zar daran festgehalten hätte ich
glaube nicht dass die anlage den russen
geholfen hätte allerdings war die
geschichte des fonds damit noch nicht
vorbei
wenige jahre später tobt hier eine
blutige schlacht die von der geschichte
weitgehend vergessen wurde
diese episode beginnt während des ersten
weltkriegs im jahr 1915 deutsche truppen
stürmen lehrjahr und besetzen die stadt
und die festung
doch das russische reich steht vor weit
größeren problemen
diese periode läutete das ende des
russischen reichs ein die großen
verluste im ersten weltkrieg und der
schwache zwar führten zu
gesellschaftlichen umwälzungen die
schließlich in der russischen revolution
hinderten
1918 hat deutschland den krieg verloren
kurze zeit später erklärt lettland seine
unabhängigkeit
die lettische unabhängigkeitsbewegung
hatte in der hauptstadt riga begonnen
doch auch in der festung von liepaja
wurde gekämpft vor allem um das sie dann
vor
die kleine lettische armee steht im
zentrum eines dreiecks konflikt sie
kämpft sowohl gegen die russischen als
auch gegen die deutschen truppen
die lettischen truppen wussten dass die
deutschen vorrücken und hatten sich auf
einen andere vorbereitet aber sie waren
nur 50 mann stark sie hätten mindestens
100 oder 200 männer gebraucht um die
festung zu verteidigen sie hätten
mindestens zehn geschützte gebraucht
aber sie hatten keines die lage war
aussichtslos
angesichts des kräfte ungleichgewichts
sind die lettischen soldaten zum rückzug
gezwungen die deutschen in die festung
wie geplant 1 doch viele von ihnen
ziehen schnell weiter und die lettischen
kämpfer wittern ihre chance
sie wussten wenn sie das vor
zurückerobern konnten sie die deutschen
vielleicht ein für alle mal loswerden
die einzige möglichkeit hier rein zu
kommen weil diese brücke sie wussten
nicht ob ihr deutsche artillerie
stationiert war und ob sie noch in der
unterzahl waren sie mussten ihr glück
versuchen und einfach rein stürmen und
genau das taten sie nicht ohne verluste
aber sie eroberten die festung zurück
ein jahr nachdem der waffenstillstand
des ersten weltkriegs unterzeichnet
worden war sind auf die kämpfe um japan
jahr vorbei
im finish war
letztlich führen aber nicht nur die
kriegsschäden zum ende des fonds der
zahn der zeit und die elemente tun ihr
übriges
am ende haben 100 jahre erosion die
forst zerstört ihnen ist von den wellen
der boden weggezogen worden und jetzt
rutschen sie langsam ins wasser
doch lettlands unabhängigkeit ist nicht
von langer dauer den großteil des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts ist das land
teil der sowjetunion die kurze zeit der
freiheit wird verschwiegen und von
vielen vergessen so sind die ruinen
heute eine wichtige stütze der
erinnerung
dieser teil der geschichte ist damals
komplett gelöscht worden komplett
umgeschrieben und die leute trauten sich
nicht darüber zu reden sogar mit ihren
kindern aus angst deswegen deportiert zu
werden
heute wollen wir an all diese dinge
erinnern damit die leute das wissen
gut 300 kilometer östlich von südafrikas
größter stadt johannesburg liegt ein
spektakuläres gebirge
[Musik]
die einsame gebirgslandschaft liegt an
der grenze zwischen zwar zealand und
südafrika das ist unberührte natur
[Musik]
im erzgebirge ist zerklüftet es ist
abgeschieden und nur schwer zu erreichen
jeder der bei hinfährt weiß genau warum
wenn man aber ganz genau hinschaut sieht
man dass der mensch dort sehr wohl seine
spuren hinterlassen hat und wie
durch das tal hindurch finden sich immer
mal wieder reste menschlicher aktivität
und wie aus dem nichts taucht plötzlich
diese unfassbare konstruktion auf
sind hohe masten stützen für eine
seilbahn
an einigen stellen sieht man die reste
von einer art gondeln
die dinge hängen es sind gondeln die
irgendwas transportiert haben aber woher
und wohin
an einem ende für die seilbahn zu einem
weiten bergrücken zwischen
den verfallenen gebäuden und rostigen
maschinen hängen mehrere seltsame loren
wenn die menschheit ihre spuren auf der
erde hinterlässt gibt es dafür immer
einen grund und der hier ist schwer zu
erkennen es ist keine
freizeiteinrichtung und auch keine
militärische anlage
was auch immer diesen enormen aufwand
gerechtfertigt hat muss am ende dieses
salz sein aber wenn es so wertvoll war
wie so wurde die seilbahn dann
aufgegeben und steht jetzt verlassen in
der gegend rum
[Musik]
im späten neunzehnten jahrhundert locken
gold und diamanten viele glücksritter
nach südafrika die folgen sind
einschneidend
die entdeckung von gold und diamanten
hat alles verändert vor allem im inland
von südafrika das nur sehr spärlich
besiedelt war und vor allem von
einheimischen afrikanischen stämmen und
plötzlich fluteten europäer das inland
um diese neuen ressourcen zu erschließen
sie bauten minen und eisenbahnlinien und
die bevölkerungszahl in der region stieg
bars und hotels schießen aus dem boden
um die wachsende bevölkerung der neuen
stadtbahn bietern zu versorgen
doch leider ist der goldrausch hier nur
von kurzer dauer die schöpfer verlassen
um anderswo ihr glück zu suchen und die
wenigen minenarbeiter die bleiben
entdecken eine seltsame substanz
sie suchten nach anzeichen für gold
vorkommen aber sie fanden etwas anderes
ein weißes fahriges material es dauerte
dann noch ein vierteljahrhundert über
sie herausfanden wie wertvoll diese
merkwürdige vater war und das sollte ihr
leben komplett verändern
das bislang unbekannte mineral bringt
neuen wohlstand in die region
doch der ist teuer erkauft
er wird von der häfler gold mining and
exploration company gefördert
logmein saß auf einem der wunder
materialien des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
das war unten in der erde und musste nur
gefördert werden diese seltsame substanz
die die bergleute jahrzehntelang einfach
beiseite geschoben hatten ist asbest
das asbest war oben auf dem berg man
konnte es leicht abbauen musste es aber
über 20 kilometer durch die lage
transportieren um es von dort weiter
transportieren zu können
wasserwege gab es nicht straßen wären
sehr sehr aufwendig und da mussten sie
sich etwas einfallen lassen und das
taten sie
52 stützen tragen das stahlseil die
gesamte entfernung beträgt 20 kilometer
als sie gebaut wurde war sie die längste
seilbahn außerhalb europas
an einem normalen arbeitstag werden 2,5
1000 säcke oder 120 tonnen asbest
transportiert
was für eine wundervolle art des reisens
[Musik]
der einheimische toni gerard kennt die
anlage gut
die idee war dass asbest zum bahnhof in
bar bieten zu transportieren und kohle
wieder mit zurück zu nehmen um damit die
generatoren zu betreiben ein problem mit
der seilbahn war dass man die fracht
austarieren musste also die güter die
rausgehen asbest und die kohle die
zurückgingen mussten gleich schwer sein
wenn man sich gedanken macht und sein
hirn anstrengend ist dass die
naheliegende lösung die stützen sind
schön leicht und lassen sich gut den
berg hoch transportieren dann
zusammenschrauben das seil spannt und
schon hat man dieses frustrierende
karussell
das material wird mit loren auf dem 20
kilometer langen kreislauf transportiert
die bahn hat insgesamt 52 stützen eine
einzelne lore brauchte für den ganzen
weg zwei stunden hinter mir sind die
großen schuppen in denen das asbest
gelagert wurde es kamen 50 kilo säcken
an und wurde dann mit der bahn nach
johannesburg gebracht
johannesburg exportiert als best in alle
welt die nachfrage steigt ob als dämmung
für häuser und elektrische leitungen für
zement bremsbeläge oder fertighaus teile
die einsatzmöglichkeiten sind vielfältig
30 bis 40 tausend tonnen asbest wurden
jedes jahr in alle welt geliefert
jahrzehntelang ist die miene der größte
arbeitgeber in swasiland
tausende von beschäftigten leben in der
nahegelegenen stadt bombo sie ahnen
nicht wie hart das schicksal sie treffen
wird
keiner wusste von der tödlichen gefahr
dieses material am wenigsten die die es
ab bauten
die sehr feinen asbestfasern die dem
material seine erstaunlichen
eigenschaften geben machen es so tödlich
us pastors als best enthält
mikroskopisch feine fasern die in die
lunge gelangen und krebs und viele
andere tödliche krankheiten auslösen die
arbeiter bekam nicht nur wenig geld sie
mussten mit ihrer gesundheit und mit
ihrem leben bezahlen damit die mine
weiterlief
tatsächlich sind die gefahren von asbest
schon lange bekannt doch erst in den
1960 er jahren ist nicht mehr zu leugnen
wie schlimm es wirklich ist das asbest
produzenten haben die gefahren dieses
materials lange heruntergespielt
das mikroskopische fasern die lunge
eindringen und krebs verursachen können
und zwar nicht nur bei menschen die
asbest ausgesetzt waren sondern erst
recht bei den arbeitern
als die gefahren von asbest immer mehr
ins bewusstsein der öffentlichkeit
geraten werden die britische
minenbetreiber turner und new mit einer
flut von schadenersatzforderungen
konfrontiert
selbst für den größten asbest hersteller
der welt bedeutet das das ende
plötzlich war diese ganze boomende stadt
nutzlos die bevölkerung schrumpfte über
nacht von 10.000 auf 600 leute dann wenn
wir uns heute umsehen denn sehen wie die
reste eines bergwerks das keiner mehr
braucht
nach der schließung der mine 2001 gehen
turner und newell freiwillig in die
insolvenz um die
schadenersatzforderungen der
bergarbeiter und ihrer familien zu
umgehen
durch die insolvenz drückt sich das
unternehmen auch vor seiner
verantwortung für die massiven
umweltschäden aufzukommen
[Musik]
doch für die stadt witten gibt es ein
leben nach gold und asbest in der stadt
sind einige der ältesten und best
erhaltenen gesteinsschichten der erde
entdeckt wurden sie sind millionen von
jahren alt und ermöglichen einen
unbezahlbaren blick in die vergangenheit
der erde und auf die entwicklung des
lebens
begann mit dem goldrausch aber die
zukunft liegt in dem wissenschaftlichen
wert dieses gestein es stammt aus der
zeit als das leben begann und es gibt in
der wissenschaft kaum eine wichtigere
frage als die nach dem beginn des lebens
die wissenschaft ist die zukunft von
bieten und sie zieht besucher aus aller
welt an
das lässt auf eine andere und bessere
zukunft hoffen eine zukunft die von
touristen statt von asbest lebt
heute sind sie vergessen und verlassen
manche ruinen waren einst leuchtende
beispiele für technologischen
fortschritt und hoffnung andere erinnern
an dunkle zeiten und menschliche
abgründe
[Musik]